you right Lads you right Lads but what
do you think of this view it's really
gorgeous it's unbelievable isn't it
reminds me of isington
let me tell you something yeah I was
just we were just saying that this
doesn't this change your mood now this
is a a stunning and gorgeous
scenery really beautiful what's good is
that it synthesizes between the greenery
and the Shrubbery on the one hand and
the mountainous one beautiful to
another you know the people will know
thank you much
sir this is Central Geneva this is like
the square where the everything is you
can see it's quite a sunny day
today kind beautiful place we're here in
the center of
Geneva we done some very important
meetings this is the morning times we're
going to have some yes
yes this is where are we now Continental
so we're approaching the M
blong mountains in France U you know
France is was very close so this is the
m Blanc
mountain yeah which is the highest
mountain in Western Europe and the
second highest mountain in Europe after
the caucus
mountains traic turn right
on for